since the last time I covered making
local chat interfaces with open source
models gradio has had some updates and
I've learned a little bit more so let's
go ahead and see how to make a local or
hosted chat interface like this one to
start we'll import gradio for the
interface of course Transformers for the
model and inference of that model and
then finally threading which we'll use
to make a stream of text from the model
which really makes just such a huge
difference to the actual user experience
even if it's just you that's using it in
effect you're basically getting
instantaneous responses back and in many
cases it can stream faster than you can
read so it just makes it almost like an
instant feedback then we'll specify
model ID which corresponds to the
hugging face model keep in mind that the
model that you choose will likely have
some specific prompt structure if you
want to make a chat bot like what we're
doing here it's important that you note
The Prompt format for the model that
you're using so whatever it was
fine-tuned with you're going to want to
mimic that many if not most models are
actually robust enough to probably zero
shot figure out the structure that
you're using and continue with it but
for best results you really should be
using whatever the model creators used
to fine tune that model so in this case
I'm referencing any of the instruct
model variants but you could also I
suppose create a sort of chat interface
with some of these base models again
just sort of zero shotting The Prompt
structure but in this case we're going
to be using the instruct variants which
instruct and chat are basically the same
thing so then we're going to define the
model itself and where we want to run
the model with the device map in my case
I'm going to go with auto so it'll load
onto my gpus from here we specify
tokenizer and then I'm adding a brief
description for the application itself
to show on the page which we'll do with
the gradio element and you'll see that
when we get there next as a quick
assigned I hosted the larger stable
Beluga model a 70 billion parameter
model it's actually still live right now
at Cyber IO slash chat but take note
it's linearly processed so there very
well may be a gigantic cue to use it now
that I've brought it up or that it's
crashed entirely or I've stopped hosting
it for any reason at all anyway upon
sharing this model publicly and kind of
sharing it on Twitter and stuff and
seeing what people are doing with it I
noticed how few people understood the
system prompts purpose so I just wanted
to add an explanation for it so that's
what we're doing here also this is part
of the benefit of working with some of
these open source models so now you can
sort of modify these the quote-unquote
system prompt of things like chat GPT I
don't think you can for anthropic's
Claude for example but stable Beluga
especially but even llama 2 are both
models that are Rel you know they they
come out of the box with very safety
focused system prompts and then the
actual model like chat GPT for example
is very heavily biased and has like
safety rails and stuff towards answering
things and not offending anybody whereas
the Llama 2 model it does come with a
system prompt that is fairly safety and
guard raily but using the system prompt
you can actually elicit a lot of other
behaviors from it and especially the
stable Beluga model you can do quite a
bit by modifying both that system prompt
and then also just sort of injecting a
you know fake history so to speak if you
really want and then building from there
next for the system prompts I give a
list of some example system prompts
which I'll let people pick from in a
drop down menu as well as if they want
they can write their own entirely I'll
then make a prompt build function which
takes the system prompt the user input
and the history of all inputs and
responses from up to that point
essentially to then construct the actual
prompt format for the particular model
that we're using and this is what I
meant you will want to mimic The Prompt
structure that whatever model you're
using was formatted on if you're using
any of the stable Beluga models then you
can use the exact code I've used here
all right now that that's done we'll
build the chat function which is going
to take the input from the gradio app
itself build the prompt for the model
tokenize it Define the streamer and now
I'm actually wondering if I actually
could just Define this outside of the
chat function pretty sure I could but
moving on anyways we'll specify the
model generation keyword arguments or
quarks which are just what we would
normally have passed straight into
model.generate but we're defining them
here so that we can pass them into the
thread call in our case we'll pass the
model inputs which will be the tokenized
prompt basically then the streamer
object so that we can stream max length
which is the max length for this model
do sample is true for basically sampling
from a probability distribution so I.E
don't be greedy but you might want to be
greedy I suppose if you want anyways
then we'll set top P temperature and top
K all things that you can feel free to
Tinker with on your own if you want next
we'll set up our thread object targeting
model.generate and passing those quarks
and then we'll start the thread from
here we can pull the streaming text from
that streamer object and add it to the
model output while we're still streaming
we'll yield the model output and when
we're done we'll return the gradiochat
interface element supports using a
generator like this for streaming text
into the UI so that's how we're
combining both the streaming text from
hugging face Transformers and the sort
of live streaming of text from the model
into the UI for the user as an aside the
actual streaming of the chat interface
can also be combined with any streaming
API for example so if you are using chat
GPT or the openai API you still could
stream into your app if you if you
wanted okay so up to this point we've
actually got everything we need except
for the UI itself pretty much so we'll
start setting up the gradio blocks
structure which just stacks these
elements in order essentially so we'll
start with a markdown element with our
description then the system prompt
explanation then we'll add a drop down
element for the preset prompts setting a
default along with allowing people to
set their own custom just by typing it
in if they want and then finally we add
the gradiochat interface element with
the chat function which we will also
specify the drop down as an additional
element since our chat function actually
depends on what system prompt the user
has selected we actually want that to be
a an input into this function from here
that's it we launched the application I
set API open to false and show API
defaults mostly I'm doing this for the
hosted app that I'm actually myself
hosting publicly this may change
eventually but I think there's actually
a bug with the API you might not even
notice it but when you do host it there
is like a little API Link at the bottom
you can click that and get API endpoints
so you really not just get a chat
interface you actually get a fully
functional API so essentially gradio
automatically builds a sort of API for
your app which is super cool I was like
I got like Goosebumps when I like
stumbled into that but it doesn't seem
to actually work with the chat interface
or maybe it's the streaming maybe it's
the threading that I'm doing I'm not
really sure uh maybe something to dive
into later or if you're someone that
works at gradio maybe take a peek into
that and let me know why that didn't
work if it was something I did wrong or
fix the bug I suppose other than that
I'm setting the server name to
0.0.0.0 I think I got that right purely
so I can access this UI from any machine
on network this includes if you're
hosting the machine with a public IP you
can just go to that IP and then port
7860 and you can actually use that app
all right so that was maybe in your eyes
a lot of code but really it's pretty
much all boilerplate code we're just
connecting a bunch of little elements
here so if you have any questions or
confusions feel free to comment below
but we've done our import specified or
model tokenizer we wrote a simple
description a system prompt explanation
and a bunch of example prompts then we
have a function that takes new input
from the user and builds the full prompt
in the format that the model that we're
using is expecting then we have a chat
function that takes the raw user input
the full history so far and the system
prompt up to this point defines the
streamer that should probably be defined
outside of this function at the top
defines the generation quarks for the
model dot generate spins up a thread and
then a little generator to grab the
streaming text back from the model then
all we do is build the UI on top which
passes in those descriptions makes the
drop down for the system prompts and
then adds the chat interface element
that's powered by the chat function and
Bing Bang Boom we have our app okay and
up to this point you can use it just
fine like this provided it fits into
your memory either on CPU and RAM I'm
sorry if that's you or onto your actual
GPU so it's actually relatively fast
there are other stable Beluga sizes from
this 70 or 7B or 7 billion parameter to
a 13B and then the full 70b there is a
30-ish billion llama 2 model that as far
as I know has not yet been released due
to I'm not sure uh you know safety or
guard raily stuff from meta so we're
kind of just waiting on that uh there
are also a ton of other instruct models
on hugging face that you could check out
to get one that just fits so perfectly
into your machine's uh setup so just
don't forget to style the prompt to be
exactly whatever that model wants so
here you can see an example of the model
helping us with some basic matplotlib
code as a just quick example and again
just the little stuff that gradio has
done for us like formatting this python
snippet I that's just so cool with the
syntax highlighting and all that this
would be a nightmare to have to do all
by yourself anyway this is just a really
quick example and just take note too
this model this stable Beluga model is
actually a general purpose model it
didn't have to be doing programming
stuff you could ask it for anything that
you might ask Chad gbt alright so that's
cool but at least for me locally it
takes up a whopping 27 gigabytes of vram
I think full Precision might still fit
on a 24 gigabyte card that other three
might be some sort of caching or
something going on but we can actually
get this to be quite a bit smaller and
maybe even eke out a little more speed
along the way to start we can import B
float 16 from torch and then write a BNB
config which is bits and bytes if you
don't have bits and bytes you can pip
install bits and bytes all one word this
config can then be passed to our model's
definition which will load our model in
as four bits using normalized float4
where possible otherwise B float 16. and
with that instead of our model taking 27
gigabytes of memory it takes 5.2
gigabytes under load you'll likely also
see a speed up as well in inference it
is important to note this is degrading
the data type from 32-bit down to 4-bit
in most cases for most findings the
actual degradation in in like model
performance when you use quantization
like this is minimal if even noticeable
at all and is usually worth it alright
finally we've made it this far you could
walk away yet again but I tend to be a
little tired of the default styling of
gradio apps since you basically see
these everywhere now especially if you
spend any time on hugging face
especially in spaces which are basically
hosted gradio apps so I started diving
into the customizing and The Styling and
this is where I admittedly know the very
least about garageo but I'll share my
findings so far and uh radio people can
likely have a chuckle at me struggling
to understand some really basic stuff
anyway so first off gradio actually
comes with a handful of themes that you
can start from you can create your own
themes and or you can customize just the
colors of those themes and then you can
even change things like the font I opted
to take a pre-existing theme after
checking out some of the other themes I
really just didn't I was just like
annoyed at all the curves and all that
stuff for the corners I really just
wanted something boxy and I found a
pre-existing theme that really looked
the way I wanted I just maybe wanted a
different font and colors so to start I
imported the color class from the gradio
library so that I could Define my own
now I'm just going to go ahead and paste
in the colors I have absolutely no idea
what these names like correspond to like
why 50 why 100 why 950 like I just don't
know I what I do know is they do
correspond to different things through
trial and error and as you can see my
comments as such of what I figured out
so far I am sure it is documented
somewhere
um I just couldn't find it quickly and
went with trial and error the only other
change that we make is with the
statements
gradio.blocks in there we're going to
pass the theme that we want to use in my
case this is one of the many gradio
themes already made I specify a new
Google font that I want to use and then
we get to the next area that I'm totally
baffled about primary Hue secondary Hue
and neutral Hue what the heck are these
who knows really but neutral Hue is
definitely the main app Coloring or so
it seems I've only ever seen the primary
Hue colors as far as I can tell when
responses are loading and then the
secondary Hue color seems to have at
minimum something to do with the color
of URLs again I that all seems very
confusing to me and given how obvious
and clear the rest of gradio is I'm
guessing I'm just missing something
extremely glaring but this is what I've
done
so to the gradio people I apologize for
totally butchering that but with that
done here is our updated styled app it
may not be in your taste but you are
totally free to take what I've done here
and implement it to one of the other
themes or change colors and so on or
comment below about why I'm so stupid
then I don't understand what those
things mean
anyway so pretty cool I think in the end
uh this gives me basically all of the
control that I could possibly want for
customizing a streaming chat interface I
could there's no way I could do
something like this on my own and so the
fact that gradio makes it this just
simple to set up a streaming chat
interface uh just for models when you're
just trying to like check them out and
play around with them uh it's it's huge
besides gradio hugging face also just
has so many models coming out and you
know I just find that I just am
constantly trying to Tinker with them in
console and mainly I want to do that
because of the streaming so sometimes
you'll wait up to maybe a minute or more
to see the model's response when you
could just stop and try something else
if you see it's going in the wrong
direction or at least be actively
reading it as it's generating it the
models almost all of them will
especially on GPU can output at least
tokens faster than you can read or at
least close to it so having gradio
stream is basically giving us a way for
that in the UI AI to have an instant
response back from the model So yeah
thank you to the gradio team for those
updates and then also take note that if
you're not familiar with gradio there
are certainly many more things than just
uh streaming chat for machine learning
models it's essentially Geared for UI
for just about all kinds of uh deep
learning or machine learning as well as
like data science and so on anyway
that's all for go build some chat apps
I'll have a link in the description to
the code used here if you want it and
otherwise check out the neural networks
from scratch book at
nnfs.io and I will see you all in
another video